Souvenez vous il y a plusieurs mois quand je vous avais présenté les chaînes coréennes
Je me suis trompé de t-shirt, clairement
Je vais aujourd'hui vous présenter, les meilleures vidéos
Japonaises de Youtube selon moi, euh... elles sont extraordinaires
tout simplement extraordinaires
Voici la chaîne TOKAI ON AIR
C'est un trio ils ont 1 million 700.000 abonnés
ils font des vues de ouf , ils font clairement une vidéo par jour
et chaque vidéo fait presque plus d'un million de vues
et j'ai quelque chose en commun  avec ces gens c'est que...
j'adore le prout
vous le savez je , j'adore , j'adore le prout
Le prout me fera rire éternellement , et c'est bien
Par exemple la je suis de mauvaise humeur , quelqu'un rentre dans mon bureau fait un prout
je vais être de bonne humeur , c'est quelque chose de bien , c'est positif
alors vous pouvez dire t'es pas mature etc.
Mais au moins je suis heureux ok ?
Je suis pas ici pour souffrir ok ?
Pour être honnête avec vous je suis tombé sur cette vidéo et j'en ai regardé aucune autre
Je voulais vous faire plaisir en découvrant les autres avec vous
mais celle-la est ... je pense que ce sera la meilleure c'est sûr
bien sûr vous vous dites
"mais qu'est-ce-que c'est que ce bordel?"
alors je vous explique !
ces deux mecs sont dans un bain remplit de je ne sais quel liquide
c'est de l'eau plus quelque chose
j'ai l'impression que c'est du slime mais je sais pas
bref
la propriété principale de ce liquide c'est qu'il va retenir les gaz
du coup ces japonais malins se sont dit :
"et si on se met dans le liquide et qu'on arrête pas de péter? peut-être qu'à la fin en prenant un peu de liquide, on pourra l'allumer avec un briquet et ça fera une flamme"
hé fallait y penser mec
donc pendant une bonne partie de la vidéo, ils vont juste manger des trucs
et montrer leur bite
puis des prouts vont arriver
voilà, le mec vient de lâcher 4 énormes prouts au calme dans son bocal
donc ils le referment à chaque fois
et dès que l'un des deux à envie de péter, il l'ouvre, il pète dedans et le referme
voilà
c'est.. c'est horrible
désolé c'est la pire vidéo mais..
ils se sont donnés tellement de mal mec
juste pour péter dans un bocal
ça m'a fait marrer
"nice"
c'est terrible
et attention messieurs, dames, il est l'heure du moment de vérité
ont-ils assez pété dans le bocal pour qu'à l'ouverte de celui-ci
quand tu met une flamme, ca fasse heu... carrément une bougie
*étonné*
*choqué*
non
*rires*
mec
put*** ils ont réussis a faire une bougie avec leur pet put*** c'est le rêve de ma vie
bon voila ca c'était une petite introduction pour vous montrez ce qui m'as donnez envie de  faire cette vidéo
les chaines YouTube coréennes c'étaient drôles hein ,les chaines youtube japonaises c'est un level si tu veux au-dessus
c'est vraiment heu... c'est le prout quoi , put*** !
Est-ce qu'ils ont fait d'autres trucs sur le prout mec parce qu'en vrai
je sais pas ce qu'ils font d'autres..."The Naughty Fart Whistle"
c'est quoi ça ?
c'est nul..
ah je crois qu'ils font un test des objets qui font des bruits de pets mec
on en est la
attends c'est quoi ca ?
non,non,...me dis p...non c'est pas ce que je pense non
mais...
mais il est en train de lui souffler dans le cul
il lui met de l'air dans les fesses
mais arrete !!
mais il s'est chié dessus là...!
oh il me fait des frissons mon pote
j'arrete,j'arrete
oh putain les mecs on réussi a me faire detester le prout quoi.
qu'est ce qu'il fait la
qu'est ce qu'il fait la ?!
il lui mettait un doigt dans le cul ...?
Non je crois qu'il mettait son doigt dans un truc
qui avait une partie de se truc dans son ...ou j'essais de me rassurer je sais pas
Bon en tout cas, excellente chaîne YouTube
Ah, une Youtubeuse japonaise
Quesqu'elle fait ?
*explosion de rire*
Ho ! j'lai vécu comme une agression.
Je me suis fais agressé là.
Ho put*** !
C'est quoi sa ? Attend lecture automatique sa part en vrille là
Mais mec, ils ont un délire avec le prout c'est un truc de ouf !
Je savais pas du tout ! (moi non plus xD)
ok.
là je crois qu'on ait sur la playlist "prout"
du Japon. Bon les amis je crois
Que...qu'on as ass...on a assez entendue de  prout pour euh...
un an là...hein ?
Y'as donc se délire des prouts que j'ai découvert et
et y'as un autre délire, que je ne connaissais pas du tout
c'est les hamsters vous saviez ? (bah oui xDD)
En gros, au Japon, ils sont ultra fans des hamsters.
Et vous savez la vidéo trop connu du hamster qui se met à bouder